Margaret Thatcher, the first female British Prime Minister, died Monday at 87 following a stroke.
Known as "The Iron Lady," Thatcher transformed Britain...
...by radically rolling back the State during her 11 years in power.
Prime Minister David Cameron cut short a trip in Europe to return to Britain...
...after the death was announced.
And the real thing about Margaret Thatcher is that she didn't just lead our country,...
...she saved our country.
Former German Chancellor Helmut Kohl praised her work.
She was one of the most exceptionally gifted Prime Ministers there ever was.
In many situations and in confrontations on the economy, she stood her ground.
You could only speak of her with great respect,...
...even if on some things you were of a different opinion.
Former US Secretary of State Colin Powell recalls her work with Mikhail Gorbachev.
It was Mrs. Thatcher that really said to the other leaders of the Western world...
...when she met Gorbachev for the first time and made the famous expression,...
..."We can work with this man."
Well, not every leader would have taken that kind of chance with a new Soviet Chairman coming in...
...who was young and vigorous and was defending the Soviet Union.
The British government said Thatcher would have a ceremonial funeral with military honors...
...at London's St. Paul's Cathedral.